when we started working on the Master
Chief collection we knew we had an
opportunity to do something special to
not only rekindle our fans memories but
to also introduce a new generation of
fans to the Halo universe the collection
features features a single unified
interface to give you all four games
with everything unlocked on one disk in
a single seamless interface so you can
play the Chiefs journey however you want
now unlocking everything that the offset
also lets us do something else we're
going to create custom playlists taking
great moments from all four games and
combining them together yeah it's pretty
cool now as many of you know November
marks the 10-year anniversary of Halo 2
and I am excited to tell you that halo 2
is getting the full anniversary
treatment we've retouched we've
retouched every part of the game and of
course you can switch from new to
classic at the touch of a button
now halo two's multiplayer was special
for a lot of reasons and we wanted to
keep that intact so halo 2 anniversary
will contain the original Halo 2
multiplayer exactly as it shipped 10
years ago in addition we selected six
iconic halo 2 maps to recreate with the
power of the Xbox one like to show you
guys some gameplay on ascension with the
help of our pro players today hey guys
everyone ready alright okay let's go so
we're going to be showing you gameplay
from ghost Leo because he's a lot better
than I am yes we are playing Spartans
versus Elise okay thank you you also saw
their a dual wield another big main
stage
a paler G gameplay and as I said we are
playing Spartans versus elites this is
actually one of my favorite maps got
some great sight lines you can really
see the vistas popping here as well
that's just a sneak peek of what's
coming your way November 11th the Master
Chief collection has over 100
multiplayer maps that is every map ever
released on Halo 1 through 4 all running
on their original engines all running at
1080p 60 frames per second on dedicated
servers and finally because achievements
are awesome the Master Chief collection
will ship with 4,000 gamerscore
thanks Marty that's a huge amount of
gameplay but in addition to great
gameplay we wanted to lay the foundation
for the future so included in the Master
Chief collection is halo nightfall our
live-action digital series created in
collaboration with executive producer
Ridley Scott and director Sergio mimic
eglise on the series introduces a
pivotal new character in a story that
leads right up to halo 5 guardians and
as you can see halo night follows
currently in production and we're
thrilled to have this opportunity to
work with such an amazingly talented
team and last but not least the final
piece of the Master Chief collection
this December we bring you the halo 5
Guardians beta it's a celebration of our
arena multi-player legacy and the beta
will debut new game modes and features
so here's just a small taste of what
you're going to experience this holiday
enjoy